yeah welcome to this video playing black
against Eva heart from let's say I don't
know German flag and I don't know who
that is I also asked couple of my
friends play on a sec if they knew who
these guys and they didn't know and he's
not playing also I hope he's not away
from the desk or something I know his
his his on ok so what to play let's play
it solid for once g3 your cam come let's
see let's see if we got the Catalan or
already a Catalan take on c4 this is the
absolute main line of them of the
Catalan Rida 5 as a sideline I play I
play this weird move because I keep
forgetting the theory are from 96 this
is an interesting alternative actually
it's not so on so sound as 96 but it
leads to interesting play with the Queen
some would really be placed on a six but
you've got some play with rock da 10 c5
white players usually don't have already
made plan against this and this already
looks like um black should be in quite
decent shape let's give him this this
isolated pawn
let's what about b5 can i play be 5 p-5
95b should be seven should be all right
yeah I'm wondering isn't black already
in very good shape here next move should
be seven I've got our pieces developed
some pressure against the deponent what
exactly is why doing yeah of course need
to go here and what now does he have
some some brilliant idea I'm just
threatening i take c 5 exchange they
offer all it's an active pieces
okay so if i go it takes me five
interesting night here hmm
I can take here I mean it's not not a
problem a b5 Queen B 5 rupee 5 i have f
Queenie five okay someone takes on g2
now M so everything's very very nice so
the check now the check looks very
natural cleaner three Quincy to it's
very quite embarrassing for white let's
get out of the a file and if you move
the king it's also not exactly great
okay so Quincy too but look at you is
got lucky too this is this is the point
and this sum is in fact quite okay for
him so what else Knight to g5 it's not a
bad move I can go nats III maybe
yeah the only question is how good is
this is this just slight edge or big
edge on whatever it looks very
comfortable maybe you should go Knight
c3 now using this pin
so Bishop somewhere to get out of night
65 threats okay it's not a real threat
yeah it's not really a big big issue
Bishop f6 takes it takes me yeah it's
not it's not really spectacularly good
what about night to breathe for
something like this
it's not not great
you
night before can just take time so
really not not leading to much okay so
normal move I completely forgot about
that but ok so hopefully not not a big
problem yeah maybe I sports some of my
advantage
yeah he sacked the exchange it's not
it's not really enough compensation but
it's it's close it's typical typical
blitz compensation I want to active play
rookie to and stuff don't want want to
stay passive
check
yeah 24 or something it's a bit this
somewhat annoying end game with a big
pond yeah exactly this is quite quite
typical maybe i can i can play on of
play from ATM his clothes his animating
net king edge for gage to mate if i get
a second rook I look on the second rank
I IFIF ideas for checkmate can maybe
play g5 ideas rookie 82 yep of course he
said he saw that
time morning
check
I can just take a 15 seconds on silly
game
check
you
check
check
yeah this guy beat me twice now from
completely completely crap positions
yeah even at the end I mean this is just
just good for black cumin so no way that
white is better I mean yeah maybe maybe
don't know it's complicated stuff but
I'd like mean I should at least be able
to draw yeah in blitz it's very tricky i
tried to sacrifice but he's got root c7
yeah group c six maybe of course this is
this is just complete prep disposition
for white and I really need to punish
this and I didn't manage yeah probably i
need to take on a 4 1st or or this and
just exchange this seems to to save him
the position is of course very good for
black probably it assume i should just
take and take on a form
so not not define Hannah take take take
yeah this is the simple solution of
course and this is because of the be
porn just better for blankets it's clear
that if I've just looked like the the
good normal moose and this probably just
wins the people on how does he protected
after the v8 probably not at all yeah
shame the good thing about this position
would be that he has I've got no counter
play whatsoever in the game I mean okay
this is the typical kind of sacrifice
that's not not real compensation that
you can you can do it in a blitz game
yeah computer just gives a six with with
clear advantage look like for example so
i thought i would have this discount to
play word he's got Queen g4 and
fortunately yeah thnkx an interesting
game